Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is my
house of the dragon season 2 video all about
how Stark coming back into the story Winterfell is
great to finally go back up there after so much of
the main show focused on their characters later
in the timeline so I'll explain who all the new
main Stark characters are and what their role in
the story is compared to the story during Game of
Thrones because there are a lot of familiar events
and types of characters archetypes references to
what's happening now later in the timeline least
of all the white walkers the wall the night King
aegon's prophecy of A Song of Ice and Fire I'll be
doing all kinds of house the dragon bonus videos
during the off season be sure to subscribe to
get them all but during House of the Dragon
season 1 we didn't see a lot of the Starks
we saw a little bit of house Stark like Rick
and Stark here was the current Lord of Winterfell
and benthanita rhaenyra when she was much younger
gusting out of the distant North irecon Stark
Lord of Winterfell absolute Darkness but aside
from that they only mentioned them again
during the finale and that was about it
like just a name drop because they're going
to be much bigger during season two there
has never lived a stark who forgotten oath
and with house Stark the north will follow
in one of the reasons why they're so much closer
to rhaenyra's side in the dance of the Dragons
is because they went through a similar event
that was happening to rhaenyra right now with
the greens trying to steal the Iron Throne
from her and because of a very Jon Snow type
of Reason which I'll talk about in a second but
actually going back in the timeline how Stark
has actually been much closer to the Targaryen
family just in general than you probably thought
mostly because of aegon's Prophecy and the role
the Starks played in maintaining the wall in the
Night's Watch obviously the north very important
to aegon the Conqueror and everybody that came
after him so quick history lesson on what happened
with the wall in the last several hundred years
before the conquest before aegon's Conquest all
seven different Realms had their seven different
Petty Kings and each realm had a long-standing
pack going back to the original long night that
all them would work together to support the wall
in the Night's Watch the timeline of the show is
a little more condensed than the timeline of the
books in the books the last long night was about 8
000 years ago on the show was more like a thousand
years ago but you get the idea the last long night
was several hundred years ago before for aegon's
conquest and in those many hundreds of years the
rum had grown much more lacks in maintaining
the Night's Watch like people's Sons grandsons
their successors just generally slowly stopped
caring about what was happening at the wall just
because activity at the wall had grown so quiet
so when aegon the Conqueror had his Dragon dream
and conquered the Seven Kingdoms to unite the
realm there was this greatly renewed interest
in the wall the Night's Watch in the north just
in general because in his Dragon dream he saw the
threat of the white walkers coming from the north
so here's where we get to the relationship between
the Starks in the targaryens Torrhen Stark was the
current king of Winterfell at the time during the
conquest they were still the kings of winter at
that time he bent the knee to aegon rather than
face balerion the black dread's fire because
of what aegon was doing to everyone who would
not bend the knee and even though the books only
hinted this they kind of implied because of what
they did on House of the Dragon with aegon's
dragon dream is real reason for Conquering the
Seven Kingdoms is that aegon actually told Torrhen
Stark about the dragon dream in the prophecy of
A Song of Ice and Fire and that's what convinced
him to bend the knee under aegon's role they sort
of had this renewed interest in maintaining the
Night's Watch in the wall that continues all the
way to the time of King jaehaerys who took the
Iron Throne from maegor the cruel even though
there was a lot of infighting in the Targaryen
family during that period during makeover the
cruel's Reign and over the years there had been
a little bit of acrimony between the Starks the
rest of the realm the Targaryen family especially
what happened with maegor jahiris's wife alisan
smoothed a lot of that over their relationship
with the Starks and she flew to the wall a lot
with her Dragon Silverwing flew along the wall
with her Dragon so all the way to the time of
Kenji Harris like right before visares takes
the Iron Throne you still have the throne being
very interested in what's happening in the north
this whole idea of aegon's Prophecy still being a
really big thing then we'll get to the main events
of House of the Dragon season one in the dance of
the Dragons a lot of what's happening in the Stark
family is similar to what happens in the Targaryen
family with rhaenyra in the greens so Rickon Stark
is the current Lord of Winterfell he bends the
knee to rhaenyra during this period but in that
giant time Jump between episode 5 and episode six
is like a 10-year time jump basically the exact
same thing happens within house Stark there's
this whole Battle of the succession and this is
where you get to Cregan Stark like the new main
character inside house Stark and Winterfell during
season two princess Sara will fly north and then
to Winterfell to treat with Lord Cregan for the
support of the north he's meant to be about the
same age as just Sara as raniera said oh you'll
get along just fine this would be great they'll
totally support us that's why she decided to send
him instead of sending lucerys in the books Cregan
is just a little bit older than just Sara's in
what happened during all those time jumps between
episode 5 and episode 6 is that Rickon Stark the
older Lord of Winterfell passed away before the
events of episode 6 and when that happened Cregan
was way too young to be Lord so his uncle named
bennard Stark Rickon's brother became region
until Cregan came of age but right towards the
end of the time Jump in episode 6 Cregan comes
of age and his uncle Bennard refused to hand
over control of Winterfell in the north so the
Starks had their own minor little dance of the
Dragons type of event over the battle Battle of
succession it wasn't nearly as big or crazy as
the actual Dance of the Dragons itself and when
we get to the events of episode 10 when they're
actually talking about going to Winterfell
to form a bargain with them to support the
blacks Cregan Stark has already defeated his
uncle thrown him in prison and taken control
of Winterfell what happened to Cregan between
the events of episode 6 and episode 10 though
is that after he defeats his uncle he winds up
marrying his childhood sweetheart named Alyssa
Norry they had a son who he named Rickon after
his father but his wife died soon after because
of the childbirth because of complications much
like raniera's mother you have to remember that
this is meant to be a model after a medieval
period in Real History so the technology the
science is meant to be about the similar level and
women in childbirth during that era had about a 50
percent life expectancy so it was pretty even odds
like flip a coin as to whether or not you would
survive childbirth even if you were a totally
healthy person so on the show one of the reasons
why they select Winterfell as one of the first
great houses that they want to go for is because
one they're thinking about their overwhelming
numbers of troops because the north is just so
huge they're so so many people that live there
they have a massive Army available to them and
because the relationship between Winterfell
and the veil it also sort of gives them the
backdoor support of the veil as well if we had
to have enough swords to surround King's Landing
we must first secure the support of Winterfell
the area and Storm's end so it allows them to
box The Greens in up in the north like they have
no support in the north and rhaenyra is banking
on this long-standing relationship that goes back
to the time of Cregan's father Rickon Stark and
his oath bending the knee to her one of the other
earlier reasons why jacaris and Cregan got on so
well just as Bros like two dudes just hanging out
was because jacaerys reminded Cregan of his own
younger brother who had also passed away before
the events of episode 10 like heading into season
two so both of them had recently lost a younger
brother because useris just lost lucerys to
aemond and the greens R.I.P lucerys the other big
reason why Cregan winds up being a huge supporter
of rhaenyra's side is because of a big rumor that
comes from Mushroom in the books they might change
the way this happens on the show though a little
bit there was also a rumor that when jacaerys
flew vermax to Winterfell to speak with him he
stayed there for a while like it wasn't just an
overnight trip while he was staying there joserus
fell in love with Reagan's half-sister a bastard
named Sara snow and reportedly it was this huge
scandal in Winterfell Cregan got super pissed off
finding them in bed together remember josairis
is currently betrothed to Baela so it's also a
scandal for that reason as well and the Rumor goes
on to say that jacaerys had secretly wed Sara snow
prior to them being found in bed together in
the Stark's godswood the Same Heart Tree the
same werewood that they feature all the time on
the main show supposedly after Cregan found them
in bed together and found out that they had gotten
secretly wed he formed a pact of ice and fire with
jacaris just the two of them together talking
about more Song of Ice and Fire references the
jacaerys' and Sara Snow's firstborn daughter
would wed cregan's son Rickon Stark someday so
obviously this sounds very familiar something
similar happened during the events of Game of
Thrones and Robert's Rebellion because rhaegar
Targaryen member of the royal family secretly
got married to lyanna Stark and they had a child
together now legitimate because they had been
married when the child was born Jon Snow aegon
VI the son Son Of Ice And Fire the prince who
was promised there were also a lot of rumors that
jacaerys wound up fathering a child with Sara snow
but there's no record of the child existing and
we don't know a lot about what happened to Sara
snow after these events without getting too far
ahead of the story like Cregan continues to be a
very big character so like the Starks are a big
character during the dance of the Dragons along
with the aftermath of the dance of the Dragons so
I don't want to talk too much about what happens
later in the books because it does wind up being
kind of spoilers but one of the reasons why there
are so many rumors about what jacaerys did with
Sara snow while he was up at Winterfell in this
potential new child of Ice and Fire this potential
new fulfillment of the prophecy is because all
the material that they're adapting for the show
comes from a book called Fire and Blood which is
like a Targaryen family history book and the
book is taken from third party accounts from
mushroom the court fool and this old crusty
Arch maester and frequently the archmaester
will disagree with mushroom's account of things
because all the spicy stuff in the books all the
really crazy stuff comes from mushrooms accounts
like guess what Prince jacaerys did with the
bastard up at Winterfell they totally had a child
and had a secret marriage there were also a lot of
rumors that they sort of hushed up what jacaerys
and Sara snow did because they didn't want it to
cause problems for Baela Targaryen because he'd
been betrothed to her and were near his side
along with the Starks didn't want to completely
throw her under the bus either so a lot of those
things sound very similar to what happened with
Ned Stark, Jon Snow, Rhaegar Targaryen, lyanna
Stark where rhaegar and lyanna get married have
Jon Snow and then later Ned Stark tries to cover
it all up no no this isn't uh rhaegar's son this
is my bastard I brought him back from the war I
totally had him with a random girl keeping secrets
up in the north which is par for the course as me
posting this video they haven't officially cast
Cregan Stark's character or Sara snow or the other
characters up at Winterfell we'll probably hear
about them in the next year I've already done a
couple House of the Dragon season 2 videos you can
click here to learn about the alternate ending to
season one all the deleted scenes and click
here for all my house of the Dragon episode
videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!